good evening
and merry christmas to all americans
across our great country on a very
symbolic day christmas 1991 the flag of
the soviet union was pulled down from
the kremlin's flagpole once and for all
it was the end of an era that had lasted
almost 70 years
the soviet union itself is no more on
that evening pretty much every tv news
broadcasted live the resignation speech
of the last secretary of the soviet
communist party
mikhail gorbachev
the first international reaction was
that of the u.s president george bush
senior who for three times described the
event as america's definitive victory
over communism this is a victory for
democracy and freedom however the
question that many asked themselves at
the time was how had it been possible to
get to that point the collapse of the
soviet union was a sequence of causes
internal and external old and rotten all
typical causes of a crippled system
magnified by a sequence of major errors
to discuss the collapse we must go back
a few years earlier to november 1982
gorbachev wasn't yet the general
secretary of the communist party that
role was held by yuri andropov to be
honest the idea of restructuring the
soviet union didn't start with gorbachev
but with andropov many in russia were
saying if only andropov had lived a
little longer the ussr would have
survived well when he was appointed by
brezhnev as his successor andropov was
aware that he was inheriting a soviet
union full of problems by 1982 the
soviets were at war with afghanistan the
tent with the west had failed and reagan
an anti-communist champion had ascended
to the white house in eastern europe
things weren't any better in poland
workers were demanding a decrease in
food prices and with the help of
dissident intellectuals they had founded
a movement to revolt solidarity which in
the early 80s already had millions of
members the problems however were not
fresh ones the ussr had many open
questions since its foundation and one
of these can be ascribed to one single
word historical instability since the
time of the revolution socialism in
russia claimed to be able to modernize a
nation that unlike western europe was
still trapped in economic and political
chaos it was like playing a strategy
video game pick up the ussr and you get
a starting handicap compared to other
western nations this starting handicap
generated an immature and unright
condition for the communists in power
which made them force the stages of a
modernization process that had taken
centuries in the west to put it in even
more basic terms that would piss off any
chef living in italy they wanted to make
pasta by boiling it in still lukewarm
water for some the soviet union was
created on unstable foundations economy
torn apart by the incapacity of the
imperial government working classes that
were really still underdeveloped and the
absence of really decisive cultural
movements this condition of intrinsic
failings of the system would persist
throughout the whole soviet history yeah
sure with stalin heavy industrialization
and increased centralization brought
changes in the economy they were
decisive impulse to transform the soviet
union into a nation no longer backward
the second most industrial nation in the
world yet the latent problems didn't
disappear they only festered most of the
population was no longer peasants but
workers goodbye codex and with both
stalin and his successor khrushchev and
brezhnev the economy was dictated by a
single keyword intensity when in fact
the soviets needed the opposite
extensivity to beat the west the ussr
adopted the mantra of quantity over
quality although far from the american
model the soviet one would always be
based on a farthest conception let's say
where almost everyone ended up in a
factory working to contribute to the
huge production of materials first for
war and then for civilian use and it
remains so even when in the rest of the
western world in the 80s the arrival of
a new technology began to be foreseen
information technology as promoters of a
socialist model the big problem with the
soviets was being immediately subjected
to a very strong political isolation and
economic embargoes by that advanced part
of the world the west the soviet union
was indeed autonomous but ended up being
a separate universe on its own in the
80s andropov was the first to realize
that in order to modernize the soviet
economy there were a need for money and
knowledge something that was abundant in
the west this idea obviously didn't
diminish the value and the quality of
many soviet scientists but it rather
diminished the immobility that for
decades marked the communist party as
andropov confessed in 1981 to eric milke
head of the stasi the east german secret
service the americans seemed to have
unlimited money andropov had a point
nato japan and the arab states of the
gulf contributed to financing the
american debt and its state's funds
including military spending on the other
hand the soviet union had a whole series
of social states that depended
exclusively on subsidies from mother
moscow the isolation of the socialist
countries that contributed to making it
clear to everyone that it was capitalism
that was dictating the rules of the game
and the fact that with the tent in the
70s the soviet union had taken up the
idea of opening a dialogue with the
united states and thus knocking on the
door of those who controlled the
capitalist markets was to use the words
of erikopsbum the beginning of the end
the first signs of weakness in the
soviet union appeared in 1979 when the
international markets were hit by a very
serious oil crisis the wave fell with
all its power on the soviet budgets that
relied heavily on the exports of gas and
crude oil the ussr was in fact the first
oil producing nation with more than 11
million barrels per day but it was
another energy crisis that messed up the
game not that of 79 but that of 73. in
that year a west without oil decided to
renew itself technically and
scientifically so to make itself less
dependent on crude oil exporting
countries russia instead was satisfied
to export oil to western countries and
had no incentive to innovate itself at a
meeting in 1982 andropov denounced a
very disturbing fact the soviets were
importing more and more foods such as
grain and meat from foreign countries
andropov said i don't want to alarm you
art i don't want to alarm you but he
continued in the last few years we have
wasted billions of rubles strong words
strong words from a strange man though
in reality he was pretty right because
instead of using oil revenues to invest
them in technology and knowledge for
development the soviet union used them
to do what it shouldn't do import food
that he could produce very well by
itself and give subsidies to its puppet
state the united states did nothing but
say thanks with the oil crisis in 79 the
russians found themselves with no money
left to pay for food imports and at that
point what did they do they started
borrowing money from western foreigners
themselves the first to experience the
mechanism of debts on their own skin
were the countries of eastern europe the
baltics but especially romania poland
and hungary where the need to repay
foreign debts increased social unrest
which in turn led to popular uprisings
that slowly brought eastern europe away
from soviet control the first countries
to incur debts with the international
monetary fund were yugoslavia which was
no longer aligned with moscow and then
it was the turn of the friends in the
warsaw pact already in 1970 moscow found
itself surrounded by satellite states
with negative budgets and with pockets
full of deaths with the west when a
group of dissidents created solidarno
simpoland in 1980 andropov became well
aware of one thing the inability to
intervene militarily as ussr had done
with czechoslovakia in 1968. moreover
the underlying problem was intangible
the problem was the absence of money as
pointed out by historian vladislav zubok
poland had accumulated 27 billion in
debt to western banks at very high
interest rates and for its part the
soviets didn't have the capital to repay
the debts of the poles the russians were
well aware of the implications of this
their own satellite states had become
the weak links that risked blowing up
comic-con the economic alliance within
the union republics in an investigation
by carl bernstein a journalist known for
having contributed to the unraveling of
the watergate scandal in america it was
reported that solidarity was nothing
more than a tool in the hands of the
united states and financed by the
italian bank banco ambrosiano in
connection with the vatican to undermine
the ussr from within nothing new on the
western front after all actually the
exact quote from the book is all quiet
on the western front it's just that in
italy we say that way and i translated
it literally mamma mia pizzeria
hopefully the vatican wanted to take
root not only in the very religious
poland but also in the rest of eastern
europe
and the united states well needless to
say they wanted to win the race as
bernstein reported the us embassy in the
polish capital of warsaw had in fact
become the cia headquarters on the other
side of the iron curtain undoubtedly in
poland there were already discontents
the citizens were very suffering
otherwise it would be pretty impossible
for the western secret services to
create such massive riots out of nothing
the use of secret services was something
very common on both sides and nuclear
weapons forced to act in the background
and speaking of nuclear armaments there
are those who say that the arms race and
the military spending budget contributed
to the soviet imbalance according to
mark harrison professor and expert in
economic history it wasn't military
spending that endangered the soviet
economy in terms of numbers the active
personnel in the soviet union in the 80s
amounted to more than 5 million and 12
percent of the gdp was dedicated to the
budget for the war industry in
comparison the maximum that the united
states had done was in 1963 when they
allocated 9
of gdp the us having a greater number of
allies and therefore much more resources
to draw on could tolerate with more ease
this competition which
at the end was aimed at frantically
bleeding the soviet coffers something
that the secretary of state george
schultz himself would later admit in the
80s when reagan threatened the ussr with
the installation of the euro missiles
the soviets had to intensify their
efforts by running after advanced
technologies and creating an arsenal of
more than 6 000 nuclear warheads a huge
strain for the weak soviet economy that
generated irreparable imbalances in fact
since stalin took the leadership the
soviet economy had been based on a state
of permanent war and of course neurosis
and this had pushed the russians to
prefer heavy industry first of all war
and industrial machineries at the
expense of consumer goods and as if that
weren't enough despite cosign's
unsuccessful attempts to reforms the
economy in the 60s soviets planning
which was centralized and state-based
had serious cracks in it false and
inaccurate information inflated
production costs excess materials
produced without accounting for the real
quantities needed low labor productivity
low rhythms absenteeism and poorly
exploited labor all this only widened
the gap with the overly competitive
capitalist world if you were a soviet
worker whether you worked hard 10 hours
a day or not
that salary always came so why make an
unnecessary effort the same happened
with the salaries of all the professions
from doctors to engineers which since
khrushchev in the 60s had been fixed at
a predetermined ceiling beyond which
they rarely went it's pretty logical
that without the possibility of economic
progress one doesn't have the incentive
to get better practical examples such as
these generated over time a loss of
confidence in socialism by the soviets
in the 70s and 80s in russia as reported
by historian zazlovsky workers were
passive indifferent lacking ideals and
driven by purely consumerist behavior a
pessimism also intensified by the
failure of the invasion of afghanistan
society had entered the labyrinth of
economic and social crisis the same
soviet companies subsidized by the state
didn't aim at technological innovation
investment because nothing would change
in a nation so where little food few
medicines few clothes or household
appliances were produced things were
bound to get jammed up with the crisis
of 1979 the distribution of essential
supplies became more and more complex
when under garbachov at the end of the
80s food prices conformed to those of
western free markets the damage was
complete and empty shelves in
supermarkets became the norm in russia
another internal issue that had been
building up since the 50s in the soviet
union then deepened the crisis of
essential goods the double economy today
we would call it the black economy a
shadow economy parallel to the state
economy and composed of transactions
that went under the scanner of the
soviet bureaucracy in short the double
economy deprived the state of revenue
making it flow into the black market
goods such as cars for which there were
very long waiting lists were an
excellent opportunity on which many
bureaucrats speculated this involved any
item furniture spare parts clothes and
even house construction the black market
meant that in addition to money
materials and labor were being stolen
from the state over time all over the
ussr especially the areas most remote
from moscow an underworld of businessmen
whom the historian zubo called
pseudo-capitalists
had formed these were real entrepreneurs
with money materials and workers they
controlled all of this under the table
to raise more money and earn more than
the standard salary offered by the
states constantin siemens and his book
the secret world of soviet capitalism
states under the socialist surface lies
a network of private companies thousands
of them produces weathers shoes
sunglasses cassettes with western pop
music handbags and many other goods the
owners are both small businessmen and
multi-millionaire family clients holding
dozens of companies when garbachov came
to power in 85 no politician or
bureaucrat was exempt from this under
the table trafficking the underground
economy which in the 60s was equivalent
to 3 percent of the national economy in
the 90s and the soviet union reached 13
prostitution and drugs also contributed
to a large part of the soviet
underground economy it was in this
illegality that corruption and the
mafias found very fertile ground with a
fierce privatization in the early 90s
the russian mafia found the real
treasure that was the time when the
organized crime became the true master
of the streets the dispenser of death
and violence for millions of russians
who fell into the abyss of drug
addiction and unlike his predecessors
who at least try to hide things
gorbachov instilled the idea of a lost
war he was the first to say in speeches
that capitalism won and communism didn't
attitude of a true leader many blame the
soviet nomenclatura and bureaucracy who
enjoyed special privileges and lived as
if they were a class of their own state
inertia excessive bureaucratization and
the indifference of party members had
created a huge gap between citizens and
politics the politicians themselves were
so old that they were referred to as a
gerontocracy a government of elders
bloated by nepotism and crownism and
clearly when the old guys are in power
all gathered into one party they only
care about keeping that power until they
die what about improving the economy
who then cares in the soviet union there
were two nomenclatures the political
administrative one which permeated a
single party moscow and the economic one
made of military intellectuals and
business managers that the two sides
were separated wasn't a good thing
because when the central states hence
the bureaucrats in moscow increasingly
weakened by the scarcity of money and
consumer goods began to lose relevance
and influence in the country the power
passed more and more into the hands of
the economic nomenclatura meaning those
who actually held the real resources of
a country directors who managed
industries estates and mines the same
ones who later with the fierce sell-off
of the best national companies would
turn into multi-billionaire oligarchs in
the liberal years of garbage of the
economic nomenclatura chose to play with
intelligence opening private companies
and joint ventures with western partners
by giving them valuable information
previously kept by party bureaucrats and
that wasn't all they also offered most
of their resources that the soviet union
enjoyed in abundance such as oil and gas
everything officially started with the
famous perestroika literally the
reconstruction perestroika proved one
thing that the breakup of the ussr
before garbachov wasn't a foregone
conclusion garbachov who's still alive
and is 90 years old has yet to be fully
analyzed by historians but for the
moment i will always remember this guy
for his awkward commercial
[Music]
[Music]
sometimes nothing brings people together
like a nice hot pizza from pizza
essentially with that appearance which
was paid 1 million dollars garby
implicitly admitted in front of everyone
that consumerism was superior to the
ideology of its own party the funny
thing was that garbachov always invoked
lennon's name in his rallies he
considered him a mensa but perestroika
initially presented as something
revolutionary ended up becoming the
opposite the dismantling of the whole
system the slogan was acceleration
recovering the gap with the west but in
order to do so gorbachev implemented
these reforms on the basis of two
conditions that would have got lenin's
hair fall at least the remaining ones
this totalization i'm not sure if this
word exists in english and privatization
according to some historians garbage of
acted consciously he wanted to dismantle
the soviet system piece by piece to
embrace the dogmas of economic
liberalism deceived by the benefits of
economic exchange with the west for
others garbachov was simply an idiot who
had no idea how to lead the country he
instead admitted that he was convinced
that it was impossible to reform the
country without first dismantling it
making it transparent and free from the
magical control of state censorship
hence the concept of glasnost klasnost
was in fact the sounding board of the
disaster of perestroika because the
media began to talk about those problems
in russia that were under the eyes of
all but no one could mention alcoholism
lack of food and crumbling housing and
speaking of alcohol the drinking habits
of russians is well known to the point
of being a social plague gorbachev
thought it was time to eradicate the
problem by implementing an anti-alcohol
policy the catch was however that
alcohol taxes guaranteed the state a sum
of about
666 million dollars but the ghost plan
the state planning committee under
pressure from garbage of himself cut off
that source of revenue raising drink
prices and prosecuting those coats in a
well miserable state
nonetheless the ban didn't take into
account the detail the black market the
vodka that became a luxury good ended up
again miraculously resold through the
backdoor the financial disaster was
quick to come sales of vodka dropped
from 54 billion rubles in 1984 to 11
billion in 1986. however in garbachov's
mind there were no issues this is it in
five years we'll heal ussr garbage of
reason by taking as a model what had
happened in the 30s at that time the
ussr had begun to modernize thanks to
the construction of industries and
plants erected by western companies that
on commission had also trained soviet
engineers and workers from scratch one
example above all was the american
architect albert khan who joined the
kremlin's consulting team for the
construction of more than 500 industrial
plants another example was the general
electric which oversaw the construction
of the hydroelectric power plant on the
niyapariba instead gorbachev's mistake
was to channel money into the existing
state enterprises not to create new ones
the old leaders were conservative they
were unwilling to innovate and that's
why much of the equipment that had been
purchased in the west was never used in
the old plans brilliant anyway whatever
plans garbachov and his team of
economists had for the long term well
the chernobyl nuclear disaster in april
86 erased them all together the flight
of hundreds of thousands of people from
the surrounding eras evoked scenarios
from world war ii according to the head
of the economic department nikolai
ryshkov the cost of the chernobyl
disaster for the first month alone was 8
billion rubles to paraphrase rishkov
chernobyl delivered a devastating blow
to the soviet economy people began to
whisper that it was the tainted leader
gorbachev to bring bad luck to the
country he was called in that disdainful
way because of the visible spot on his
forehead gorbachev didn't make himself
very popular in fact as he kept the
entire russian population in the dark
about the disaster for many days apart
from chernobyl garbachov went on with
his perestroika and what were the
results terrible perestroika liberalized
overnight a soviet economy that was
planned from the beginning it was a
devastating blow first government
official approved the creation of free
prices no longer controlled and set by
the state only four percent of the
citizens approved this maneuver the
result a race to the top of basic
necessities and a hyperinflation that in
1992 would have touched peaks of 2
600 percent money was rationed and in
its place a sort of consumer card was
introduced they were sheets of paper
worth various amounts of rubles with
which citizens could make purchases
without using cash money when they found
a piece of bread after how were standing
in line russians could count themselves
lucky if they could buy a half pound
loaf of bread for six dollars this
compared to an average monthly salary of
50 although the soviet standard of
living until then had always been at
least a third lower than that of
westerners citizens noticed the
difference with respect to previous
times crime especially the mafia was
lower and there was a general sense of
greater security whether this was real
or not is another story with per striker
there was a free for all for those who
wanted to do business with large foreign
multinationals an incentive from which
stamped a whole series of speculation
and fake sales like the ones of the
strategic soviet mining companies at
symbolic prices on top of that there was
the issuance of new currencies for all
the republics of the union this
increased the confusion of internal
transactions and trade in addition the
so-called property law of 1990 which
removed the state from ownership of key
industries generated 2 million
unemployed nationwide a figure never
seen before and as we know an unemployed
population used more and more alcohol
and drugs to set least by 1998 the
russian economy in the hands of mobsters
and foreign entrepreneurs would have
been almost completely halved from 1990
figures food prices had doubled and
wages were less than half while typhoid
cholera and other diseases had reached
epidemic proportions in the country it
was as if the entire nation had suddenly
gone back 80 years some such as
historian stephen cohen have called this
achievement the result of a particular
phenomenon gangster capitalism the
opening up of international markets also
encouraged the arrival of private banks
which replaced the monopoly of the state
bank soviet debt to western banks jumped
from 77.2 billion dollars in 1985 to 40
billion dollars in 1986. unlike china
wanting to reform things too quickly
also invested the political front
gorbachev knew very well that the party
and its members were the operational
corps if he wanted to change the union
structure the only way was to strip
party members of their various
departments and deprived them of their
powers with a series of reforms
gorbachev did just that he took away the
party's decision-making monopoly in
doing so however it was like beheading
the state it was a political suicide
without a head the state the body the
soviet union suddenly stopped working a
bit like unplugging a device at that
point all it took was a little push an
international event of great impact that
could maybe break up the entire instant
block oh yeah how silly this already
happened in 1989. from the berlin wall
specifically take a look at them they've
been there since last night they are
here in the thousands they are here in
the tens of thousands with a symbolic
fall of the berlin wall like a domino
all the soviet republics starting with
the baltic ones broke away one after the
other in the wake of the independence
euphoria that horrified the russian
nationalists and nationalism was the
final card the ace of spades that would
close the game the first to realize that
the rules of that game were changing was
boris yeltsin like an old fox yeltsin
exploited the frustrations of the most
radical communists and some of the
members of the secret service to break
away from garba shot's wing dress up as
a populist leader go into opposition and
support a coup against gorbachev in 1991
in the capital moscow the images of him
getting on a tank would go around the
world angering the most dissatisfied
people who were fed up with garbage
shops policies the coup failed
immediately because obviously there was
no longer a state it must be said that
70
of the population wanted to maintain the
soviet union the referendum on the
preservation of the ussr in 1991 clearly
demonstrated this but these were not
yeltsin's plans yeltsin had all the
popular support to be able to obscure
gorbachev take away his remaining
consensus and forced him to resign at
the end of august in november of the
same year yeltsin would issue a decree
with which to make illegal any activity
of the communist party and dissolve once
and for all the soviet state on december
11 1991 only two of the 15 soviet
republics were still part of the union
russia and kazakhstan the former left
the union the following day on december
12th that was the end of the ussr and
the beginning of the russian federation
gentlemen
it has been a privilege playing with you
tonight and on this special day of peace
on earth good will toward men
may god continue to bless the united
states of america
good night
it's not over yet with the exit of
russia kazakhstan became the soviet
union yep for four days until it
declared itself an independent republic
on december 16 1991 kazakhstan was
basically the soviet union oh great
kazakhstan thank you you created a
nightmare that even lenin would never
have that to dream i've been wanting to
make this video for almost a year i
tried three times previously but i
always gave up summarizing deeply the
reasons for the collapse of the soviet
union in a 30 minutes video was
unthinkable and yet here we are thanks
to all of you for listening to me until
the end see you in the next episode ciao